[موسيقى]
فاذا هذا هو المحترفه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شكرا شكرا شكرا
هذه ورشه ورشه قديمه وكل سنه هون بكون فيه
تقريبا هذا محترف ومعترك الفن
تولد الاعمال تولد حلو
ابداعات الفنانين طبعا من كل العالم انا
هذا شغلي هون
كن جميلا ترى الوجود جميلا رائع رائع
نعم يعني هو المقصود انه الخط لغه الخطيه
هي لغه الاسود وابيض لغه الحبر بالضبط
هذا الفنان ليس ابن هذه المدينه لكنه واحد
من زائريها الدائمين في استضافه من عمدتها
ورئيس مهرجانها السيد الوزير محمد بن عيسى
هو خالد الساعي تشكيلي وحروفي ويمكن وصفه
بالرحاله رحاله سوري معاصر يحمل حروفه
ويوقع جداريه هنا على جدار في المدينه
ويترك اخرى في متحف اخر ذكرى لعبوره ولوحه
في متحف ثاني
في اطار مجموعه ما ففي كل مدينه من العالم
تقريبا توجد لوحه له موقعه باسمه
هذا بيت محمد المليحي
موجه هو اللي يعني من تصميمه كانت
عجيب الشمس حتى عطيتها
[موسيقى]
التقيته هنا في اصيله في موسمها السنوي
يرسو في المره هذه جداريه بجوار المحيط
وقباله بيت الفنان التشكيلي الراحل محمد
المليحي الذي وقع حياته بموجه المحيط
ونقلها الى رصيف المدينه
كانت ازقه اصيله تجذبنا الى متاهاتها
الحميمه الى الفت بيوتها التي تعود اهلها
منذ سنوات ما يقارب النصف قرن تقريبا على
زائرين يتركون فيها عربون حب او ذكرى
ولان خالد السعي هو الان خارج مكانه
الاولي دمشق اخترنا هذا القصر قصر الثقافه
في اصيله لنقيب هذا الحوار او هذا الابحار
في الحرف العربي الذي الهم الكثير من
تشكيلي العالم بالبحث عن سر تكوينه
وكونيته
خالد الساعي حلوه الاسم الساعي يعني في
مسعى دائم يعني انت تسعى في سبيل ماذا
سؤال صعب يعني من البدايه ابتديتها
بالصعوبه يعني اسعى للفن اسعى للجمال اسعى
الحريه اسعى الى التعريف بالحرف العربي
كمنجز بصري خاص ويحمل هويه ويحمل
بطياته تراث خلينا نقول تراث متعدد وليس
فقط يرتبط باللغه لان اللغه هي هي قول
احدى اقوال الحرف لكن الحرف كمنجز بصري هو
منجز متكامل له لغه يخاطب فيها الجمال
يخاطب فيها الشعور بالعربي ممكن يقول عن
الحرف هو امه من الامم فظيعه نعم قول صحيح
لانه العالم هو هكذا العالم واقعي وتجريدي
التجريد يعني لغه واللغه هي لغه التجريب
فابن السيئه بالنتيجه العالم الموازي
لعالم الكائن هو
بحر او عالم اللغه فهي امه من الامم لكن
انا غصنا بهذا المعنى او هذا القول له
دلالات عميقه ومستويات متعدده
حروفها البارد والحار فيها اليابس واللين
وفيها حسب
الكواكب مثلا فيها حروف مثلا شمسيه وحروف
قمريه وحروف هوائيه وترابيه وحسب الابراج
جميل جميل قد تكون اللغه العربيه والحرف
العربي هو الوحيد اللي عنده هذه الابعاد
والدلالات وابعد من ذلك
هناك مقاربات بين الموسيقى والحرف
وهناك مقاربات ايضا بين الشعر وبحوره
والحرف
فبنتيجه هو مستودع وخزان كبير لهذا الشيء
يعني تخيل بصريا بصريا عندما نقول
نكتب شيء عن الحب فنتجه لحروف معينه لنوع
خط معين عندما نكتب عن الحكمه لخط اخر
عندما نكتب مثل هذا القصر او القصور
الكبيره والاواب الضخمه استخدم ايضا نوع
اخر من الخطوط فبالنتيجه الخط
الذاتي هو رساله بصريه تنقل المعنى بمعزله
عن القراءه يعني هو لغه بصريه تحيد اللغه
بذاتها
فماذا تكلمنا عن اللغه فهي لغه صوتيه وهي
لغه تصويريه بنفس الوقت بقيه اللغات
العالم لا تحمل هذا الثقل وهذا التنوع
بالدلالات يعني عندما مثلا تسمع كلامه
والو انه كلام كرر كثيرا لما قال بيكاسو
اردت الوصول الى اقصى نقطه في فن الرسم
وجدت الخط العربي سبقني اليها منذ امر
بعيد هذا مو كلام جوزيف يطلع عن فنان كبير
او حتى الشاعر برنار نويل لما قال ما من
لغه تمتلك خطا تشكيليا يرتبط فيه الشكل
بالمعنى مثل اللغه العربيه حتى
القاءه ذهب هو ابعد من ذلك تخيل يكتب
قصائد عن الحرف العربي
برنامج يكتب مثلا عن حرف الله فيقول يعني
بمعنى انه هذا حرف فاتح جناحي
خالد الساعي من مواليد مدينه حمص
ينتسب الى عائله من اصول فراتيه من مدينه
الميادين التي لا يخلو بيت من بيوتها من
عازف او رسام او فنان او شاعر هي هكذا
المدن التي تولد على ضفاف الانهار
نشا خالد وسط عائله لها علاقه بالخط
والحرف والموسيقى وهذا ما ساعده مبكرا على
تكوين شخصيته
وخياراته اللاحقه بحيث التحق بكليه الفنون
في دمشق ثم تابع ابحاثه ودراساته في فنون
الخط في اسطنبول وزااول التجاربه
التشكيليه التي بدات تتمحور شيئا فشيئا
حول الحرف العربي وتجلياته وعلاقته
بالصوره والصوت والموسيقى والهندسه والذي
فتح امام خالد بوابات المدن في الحاضر وفي
التاريخ
يعني انت يعني
فنان غادرت غادرت سوريا الوطن المكان
الاول مطارح الاولى حمص
والميادين حلب ودمشق بدون شك يعني هذا
خزان كبير خزان كبير يعني واسئله حملتها
معك وتحمل دائما ماذا يعني لك ان تجد حمص
على غير حمص التي كانت وحلب على غيرك على
غير شكل دمرت
يعني شيء مؤسف لهذا الشيء امانه على صعيد
النفسي والانساني وعلى الصعيد الشخصي
بالنسبه الي اماكن انتمي اليها واماكن
يعني هي ذاكرتي وليس جزء من ذاكرتي ذاكره
الاولى واللبنه الاولى لافكار
والاجتراحات الفنيه كلها ابتدات من نهر
الفرات ومن ومن حمص وايضا دمشق كما قلت
انا يبدو قدري اسكن الى جانب الانهار من
نهر الفرات نهر العاصي الى نهر الفرات
وبعد ذلك نهر برد تخيل نهر برد بدمشق كان
يجري في بيته يعني كان عندي بيت اكبر من
هذا القصر
في دمشق في منطقه الربا يعني كان بيت كبير
جدا من العهد العثماني للاهل لا لي شخصيا
يعني لكن
الثري بلغتي بفمي وعلى المستوى العملي انا
المستوى العملي اموري ليست سيئه نعم لكن
يعني
احاول ان اعوض عن الفقد المادي لهذه
الاشياء او
التاريخي
بالانتصار الفني يعني عملت من سنتين معرض
بفرنسا باونجي معرض ضخم 70 عمل كان هو بين
الفرات ولا الواار نهر الفرات اللي هو في
الميادين نهر الجنه نهر التاريخ ونهر
للوار اللي هو نهر الحاضر فكان بين نهرين
وهو كون الحضارات على طول هي تنمو على
الانهار تنمو على شواطئ البحار حتى
الاسطوره تقول ان نوح عندما نزل بعد
الطوفان كتب الابجديات كامله على الالواح
هو الطوفان ساهم بانتشارها عن طريق
الانهار حلوه هالخيال الجميل يعني اقبل
فيه كا اسطوره كخيال لانه تعرف يغذي ويعطي
تاويل اخر للمعاش او للواقع بالعوده الى
البيت الذي كان يعني يعبره بردا
لحفز مخيلات كثيره في الشعر وفي الرسم هذا
النهر رغم انه جف الان للاسف يعني شو مصير
هذا البيت الان يعني مجهول يعني افضل
ابتعد عن القصه عن هذا الموضوع لانه يشكل
الي جرح لانه فجاه تفقد بيت بمثابه مملكه
تصور بدمش كان كنت لا اضطر اخرج الى
المدينه ياتيني يعني
ليس المكان فحسب روح المكان وطاقات المكان
عمره هو المكان المكان عمره ممكن 600 سنه
بدايه الفتره العثمانيه وبعد ذلك تم
توارثه عن طريق العوائل الدمشقيه لكن مثلا
احيانا يصور في افلام او مسلسلات البيت
لكن البيت كنقطه يعني اشاعه ثقافي كان مهم
جدا يعني كنا نقيم فيه سهرات فنيه ونقيم
فيه مثل المعارض ورش عمل يعني هذا بشكل لك
جرح هذا الانسلاخ عنه امانه امانه هذا لا
ازال اعيش من هذه الزواده وليس من العالم
اللي طفت يعني 90% من العالمي اتمنى ان
ارجع يوما ما الى سوريا لن تبقى دمشق
بالنسبه الي يعني هي الملهمه الاولى
[موسيقى]
الفن بالمغرب العربي والفن خدمي جمالي
يعني موجود بكل مكان مو مؤطر بلوحه وهذه
احلى الحلو بقصيده لانه اللوحه خرجت
للشارع صحيح هي المتلقي بده يروح يشوفها
بالمتحف لا المتحف بالشارع وصار الانسان
هو
بلاش شعور يعيش الجمال وبالله شعور ينمو
عنده تذوق البصري
انت الان في اصيله خالد
وصلت الى اصيله برحلاتك يعني وتحمل حروفك
ايضا وهذه المدينه ايضا لها سحر خاص هذا
السحر يجذب الفنانين
الممسوين باللغه
وبالجمال ماذا قالت لك وماذا قلت لها
ان اذكر اول
اول فكره او اول مجيء لاصيله يعني سالني
بن عيسى هاتفيا انه نحب ندعيك لاصيله
فاستعرضت استعاره عن ابن عبد ربه قلت له
اني يعني اسعى الى اصيله مشيا حتى ان اردت
لانه فعلا كان في شوق من زمان اعرف واقرا
عن اصيله واعرف كم هي ملهمه من فنانينها
ومن زائريها ويعني
تمثل بالنسبه الي الكثير اصيله واجي
باستمرار وكل مره تضيف بعد اخر لان هذه
المره جئت بالخريف لاول مره قبل ناتي
بموسم الصيف موسم الصيف غليان ناس عصف بكل
المستويات بالخريف
كانه اخذ خلوه بالمدينه فهذه الخلوه
بالنسبه لي مهمه جدا فشفت هذا الشيء يعني
اعطاني هيك اعطاني نوع من الهدوء والسكينه
لكن هذا الهدوء
لم يتمثل باللوحه تمثل بعصف كبير بالعمل
الفني
[موسيقى]
اللوحه الجداريه اللي رسمتها على جدران
المدينه
هي يبدو مبنيه على بعض على نص
لصديقك وصديقنا نور الجراح لمقطع شعري نعم
ولماذا نور الجراح نوري الجراحه بمعزل عن
كونه صديق عزيز
شعر كبير وله مشروع اراه عظيم لكن بالنسبه
الي عربي اعمال نور الجراح
يعني فيه شيء جديد صوت مغاير ومختلف عن
باقي الاصوات المطروحه بالعالم العربي
واهم شيء اهم شيء اللي يشوفوا يعطي
للاسطوره والميثولوجيا والتاريخ بعد اخر
ومختلف يعني كانه يعيد
الملاحم الى الحياه
[موسيقى]
اللي بيشتغلوا على الحرف
البصريا يعني مثلك هم عندهم ميل عندهم
ميله النص الوجداني التصوفي العرفاني اكثر
وللنصوص
خلينا نقول ايضا للشعر
الكلاسيكي العربي لانه ايضا انت بتتحدث عن
علاقه الحرف في الايقاع
والزمن
الشعر الموزون عند العرب يعني في في هذه
الوحدات اللي هي فيها صوتيات وبصريات من
نفس الوقت يعني انت وقت اللي تتفلت من كل
منظومه الايقاع الكلاسيكي بالشعر وتذهب
الى القصيده النسر لتبني عليها
مناخات بصريه يمكن بكون يمكن اريح لك شوي
كمان بكون الوضع عن
المساهمات حديثيه
سؤال مدهش بصراحه لاول مره يطرح علي سؤال
من هذه الزاويه صحيح بمرحله معينه اشتغلت
كثيرا على على النصوص
الى البحور وحتى ليس فقط كبنيه بصريه او
بنيه ايقاعيه
عملت على تحويلها بعمل الفني لكن ايضا
كمنطلقات من الشعر القديم او التاريخي هي
جميله ومدهشه لكن نحن نعيش الان نعيش
اللحظه وايضا لا اتوقف عن الشعر العربي
هذا اهم شيء الاشاره العربي اكيد مهم
واصوات كثيره عظيمه يعني مثل نور الجراح
ومحمود درويش انا اشتغلت عنه اكثر الشعراء
العرب استعمال اشتغلت كثير يتجاوز ممكن 60
عمل غير نوري ومحمود لمن عملت من الاعراب
لنسبه
الشعراء التصوف بشكل كامل لعملت عليهم ابن
عربي وسهره وردي والابن الفارض والنفري
لكن انا شغلت الاهم
على ايقاع اللغه ايا كانت
يعني مثلا الشارع الفرنسي شغلت عليه كثيرا
كان عندي معرض من شهرين بفرنسا تجيد اللغه
الفرنسيه يعني اجيدها استيعاضا وليس كلاما
الانجليزي ممكن او
فشغلت عن نص الفرنسي وهذا البحث اهم البحث
تحويل الايقاع والصوره الى الى لغه مغيره
يعني من منجز لغوي الى منجز بصري طيب اذا
كانت انت ذكرتك
اللغويه وذاكرتك البصريه
ذاكره الفتها البيئه والفها الموروث
والفها يعني المكان اللي انت
عشت فيه ونشات كيف بتقدر كيف تقدر تذهب
الى نص بغير لغه لتبني على مناخات لتبني
عليه مناخات بصريه
ربما الحرف العربي
بيحفزلك المخيلي اكثر اللص الفرنسي
صعوبه او ربما وهذا يمكن ابحار في مكان
خطر شوي يعني المخاطره جزء من النجاه يعني
ومخاطره مثلا ابعد اشتغلت من اشهر قليله
معرض بالسويد
اسمه جمرات الثلج المعرض كله مستوحى من
الشارع السويدي وهنا نقطه المترجم المترجم
يعني انت تذهب الى يعني تاخذ من المعنى مش
من الحرف لا لهذا السبب اكلم عن سعر
السويدي سعر السويدي وهي نقطه مهمه جدا
اللغه السويديه هي لغه ذات جرس صوتي جميل
وذات تعبير صوتي وليس تعبير باللغه اللغه
ليست دقيقه مثل الالمانيه والفرنسيه لكن
هي كصوت هي لغه تعبيريه تحت وصرفه وتحتمل
الايقاعات وعلاقات الاحرف ببعضها علاقات
تستند الى موسيقى معينه جميله فعملت الى
تحويله لان الحرف العربي يمتلك هذا
المخزون الموازي من الاشكال بالحرف العربي
عندي قدره لا محدوده او غير
بالتوليد الاشكال والصيغه الحرفيه فعملت
نوع من المقابله بين لغه كصوت
وبمعنى حيدت اللغه المكتوبه
والمنجز الحرفي اللي اشتغل عليه طبعا
اللغه العربيه اظن فيها 13 مليون كلمه
يمكن يوجد قاموس بالحرف اوسع من اللغه انت
عندما تاخذ قصيده قصيده
وتحولها الى مناخ بصري الى لوحه الذي
يفتنك هو المعنى
ام شكل القصيده
النص يحدد احيانا يجذبني ايقاع الحروف
الصوره اللي ذهنيه لي لهذا العمل لهذه
القصيده هذا الشكل
نوع من الاختراق عن طريق الحرف لك
يؤلف عالم بصري موازي
طيب الاشتغال على على هذه المناخات اللي
مختصه باللغه والحروف بشكلها وبصوتياتها
بظلك هو
يوسع الافق امامك كتشكيله او انه يؤثرك في
هذا المناخ يعني انت بتصير ما قادر تتفلت
وتذهب الى لوحه خارج اطار اللغه يعني تحضر
برنامج ما يتخفى لغه اللغه ما يتخفى لغه
اللغه وداع المعنى
اللي يصير كيف اللغه تعطيك تعطيك صوره
وتعطيك اتجاه لكن لا تحدد لك ماهيه الصوره
الذهن هو اللي يفتحها فتفتح الافق يعني
مثلا انا لو عملت مشهد امامي واصور كرسام
وانا رسام امانه حتى لكن عندما ارسم فهي
الصوره محدده امامي المثير لكن اللغه
تعطيني الطريق
والشعر بالذات تعطيني الطريق لكن تعطيني
الغموض بنفس الاتجاه اتجه بهذا الشيء يعني
لما نقول شجره
غابه محترقه وكذا يذهب الدهن الى
تداعيات كبيره فاذا اعطاني الصوره لكن لم
يحددها وهذا الامتياز بالنسبه الي لماذا
مثير عندي اللغه اوسع من الصوره
الحرف محيط بعيد وعميق وغامض ومغر للابحار
وخالد السعي على ما يبدو يواصل هذا
الابحار في الحرف العربي وسنواصل معه هذا
اللقاء في حلقه قادمه
[موسيقى]